look said that's the core pool it's
adopting us you are coming with me right
Navi I'd never leave my little brother
we've decided to adopt one of the
brothers mr. Leslie but these boys are
inseparable it would break their hearts
sir you're sure about sending agent
graves
he's the best I ever trained
for 28 years I've been searching for my
baby brother you haven't seen anyone who
looks like this we finally here brother
he's gonna be at this posse vents amaura
finally I can make things right Nobby oh
my god because of you my shot was
compromised a huge manhunt to find the
robe secret agent now come out stay away
from me don't worry the proof you can't
help us
we've got bulletproof glass
that pellet was filled with the toxin
and I'll be dead in 90 seconds if you
don't suck it out the psychic thing can
let me die okay what would you like
written on your gravestone stop it and
in what fault would you like that bring
me sebastian graves
I washed him forever I'm useless you are
not useless who's the man who can get me
pregnant without even waking me up baby
who's the man who's never even read a
book me in a police station without even
getting arrested
that wasn't me
you don't have that's I disagree
Ukranian Ben Affleck whoa whoa raise it
I understand why you love gun so much I
mean it completely detaches you from the
guilt of your actions
will you stop shooting everything was
fine perfume compassion so hot
Lee vanished hello yonks is you know
Platts he does a